SPECIAL ELECTION BETWEEN
JUDGE ROY MOORE AND DOUG
JONES.
ALSO HUGE BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT AT THIS HOUR.
FOX NEWS HAS NOW OBTAINED A
TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN THE
FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK AND
HERE WITH THAT FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT,
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST SEBASTIAN GORKA.
HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE TO
READ THIS?
GOD, HILLARY SHOULD WIN
100 MILLION TO ONE.
I SUPPOSE HILLARY IS WHO I
SUPPORT.
HUMAN BEING.
PETER STRZOK ON ON ROBERT
MUELLER'S TEAM.
PETER STRZOK INTERVIEWED
CHERYL MILLS AND HUMA ABEDIN
AND HILLARY CLINTON AND
GENERAL FLYNN.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN THE
DOSSIER.
PUTTING THE FIX IN WITH AN
EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION ON THE HILLARY
EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
HOW IS THIS GUY WITH THIS
BIAS I'M NOT EVEN TALKING
ABOUT 8 OF THE 16, APPOINTED
BY MUELLER DEMOCRATIC
COURT BY ANDREW WEISSMANN.
FIFTH CIRCUIT OF APPEALS OR
THE FACT NO REPUBLICAN
DONORS SUPPORTED BY MUELLER.
THIS IS BEYOND ANYTHING I
HAVE SEEN IN MY LIFE.
ROBERT MUELLER SPECIAL
COUNSEL AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN THE FOREFRONT OF THAT
INVESTIGATION NOW THEIR BIAS
IS EXPOSED WHAT DOES IT ALL
MEAN?
IT IS A HOUSE OF CARDS.
AND IT SHOULD BE CLOSED DOWN
TOMORROW MORNING AT 8:00
A.M.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO AGREE WITH
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE.
SIX YEARS UNDER PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL WHO WASN'T JUST A
BUREAUCRAT.
WASN'T A PROFESSOR LIKE ME
IN A DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
INSTALLATION.
THIS WAS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
HAS BEEN TASKED TO
INVESTIGATE A SITTING
PRESIDENT TEXT MESS SAM'S
ARE CONFIRMED.
HE CONSIDERS AGREES WITH THE
PERSON HE IS TEXTING IS HE
AN LOATHESOME INDIVIDUAL.
HOW DOES THAT MEAN YOU ARE
GOING TO INVESTIGATE HIM?
WHAT IS YOUR AX TO GRIND.
HOW ARE YOU IMPARTIAL PEACE
MEMBER OF OUR GOVERNMENT?
IT IS AN UTTER OUTRAGE,
SEAN.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO ALABAMA.
GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS
RACE.
IT APPEARS VERY, VERY TIGHT.